[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Segan can I say that all right people
we're live on YouTube and we're doing
something a little different today as
you guys know this show is fan funded by
you the audience through the
crowdfunding platform patreon thanks to
those of you who support what we do on
patreon this show is not only
independent but we built a totally
professional home studio and have a
hundred percent control over all the
content that we create for you every
week there is literally nothing between
me and you because patreon has given us
the tools to create a business behind
the show one of which I'm incredibly
proud of the patreon platform has
enabled us to grow and expand the show
but also and perhaps more importantly
allowed us to build an incredible
community of people who care about free
speech and having thought-provoking and
honest conversations as most of you know
at this point last week patreon deleted
the account of former guests of the
Rubin report Lauren Southern many of you
expressed frustration with patreon and
we lost about 200 patrons and over a
thousand dollars a month in support
because people no longer wanted to
support patreon we've made some of that
money back on paypal but that's totally
besides the point as I said in a patreon
exclusive post that I put up last week
I'll respect any of your decisions
related to your hard-earned money and at
the same time patreon itself is a
private company and it can do whatever
it deems best for its business at the
same time as a creator but also as a
consumer I often find myself incredibly
frustrated with many of the platforms
that I use and the general lack of
transparency from these new media
monoliths is becoming an increasing
problem to patreon credit their CEO jack
conte called me and about half dozen
other creators personally to explain the
decision to remove Lauren's account
during that call which was just a couple
days ago last Thursday I asked Jack to
come on the Rubin report to discuss
Lauren's ban and the company's
commitment to free speech Jack
immediately responded that he would love
to come on and discuss this which is
something that CEOs of these companies
pretty much never do I suspect that the
conversation that we're about to have
will be the Nexus of so many of the
issues that we talk about here every
week from free speech to new media to
silencing of dissent to public versus
private utilities and much more with
that in mind I welcome
patreon CEO jack conte to the Rubin
report thank you all right that was my
little Prelude it's a great Prelude I
normally don't do live preludes but
there you go
all right so we have a lot to talk about
and you know I always say at the end of
my interviews that I think a good
interview is when I don't look at my
notes once a day today though I am gonna
have to look because there's a lot of
things we got to get to great but I
thought the way to kick this off would
be that I consider patreon one of the
big four at least in the world that I'm
in so we've got YouTube we've got
Facebook we've got Twitter and now
patreon I would say bit more than
Instagram more than snapchat because you
guys have given the tools to the
creators we were all frustrated about
demonization lack of transparency all of
the things that I just mentioned and you
guys have enabled not only me to do what
I do but literally thousands of other
people to do that that being said Lauren
southern yeah just lay it out why why
was Lauren this page deleted so I made a
video about this and posted it
late last week yeah the main reason the
page was deleted was because she you
know and this crew folks on this boat
basically pulled a boat in front of one
of these NGO ships which for us cross
the line between speech and action and
we went through the content policy and
you know there's a line in our policy
that prohibits folks from like taking
action that could lead to somebody dying
like if you if you block a hospital
entrance or if you park your car in
front of an ambulance you can't do that
it's against our it's against our
content policy very simply like at the
end of the day that's why we took down
our page so a lot of people were saying
we're first asking me well how did this
come to your attention yeah so this is
one of the things that I asked so we
talked for about 20 minutes just didn't
flow transparency yeah and we just met
for another two minutes right here yeah
but that was one of the things that a
lot of people read well how did this get
to your attention so there seems to be a
little confusion as to whether this was
bumped up by people complaining to you
meaning just AB you know patrons or just
people outside of patreon right that
maybe we're tweeting at you guys or
whether this was from this group hope
not hate that lobbied yeah to make this
happen yeah so I'm gonna sound probably
a little dumb here
but I actually hadn't even heard of this
hope not hate lobby thing until someone
I said I think I saw a tweet about it
maybe Saturday or Sunday I didn't even
know that people were accusing them of
having lobbied for this and I know very
little about that organization so I can
tell you how things get bumped up in our
system we start seeing an influx of
reports about something we saw the same
with IgD suddenly there was this massive
influx of reports about IgD the same
thing started happening with Lauren and
as like more and more reports start
coming in the urgency of that thing
starts to get intense especially if the
complaints coming in are like giving
detailed evidence or have screenshots or
I mentioned in this video there's this
concept called manifests observable
behavior that makes it a little easier
if somebody has done something that's
like literally trackable traceable
there's a tweet of it there's a
screenshot there's a video and when we
start getting a you know a lot of those
sorts of reports the team will escalate
the thing and make a decision so that's
exactly what happened and then you know
when was it two weeks ago that we made
the decision to take the page down right
so as far as you know it wasn't lobbying
because it sounds like because at least
there are some tweets that would lead
people to believe that hope not hate did
Lobby you guys but you're saying as far
as you know that's not how it got on
your if they Lobby patreon they didn't
lobby me yeah yeah can you talk a little
bit more about manifest observable
behavior because I watch your video
obviously and I never heard the phrase
before I like to think that I yeah know
a little bit about these types of things
um was that phrase itself actually in
the the TOS the Terms of Service yeah oh
it in our in our content policy when we
talk about how to scale the team and how
to make a good decision how to make sure
that you're not making decisions based
on ideology or other things we use this
term manifest observable behavior and
really what it means is look you don't
know a person's intention right you
don't know what their motivation is if
someone says you know if someone says I
am going to burn down the DMV and then
they make a video of themselves burning
down a building and then they
you know whatever they raise money and
they buy gas and matches you know those
things add up and you can you can see
the the campaign to raise money you can
see the threat in the you know in
Twitter you can see the the statements
from the person you can see a video of
them burning down another building
practicing those are all examples of
like manifests observable behavior
here's a person who is like burned down
a practice building they have made a
threat and add up to what we would call
like a credible threat right so I think
a lot of people would hear that example
and say yeah that's a that's a pretty
concrete example what I'm hearing from a
lot of Lauren's people is that the that
what happened with these boats that a
there's an argument to be made that what
these boats are doing is illegal that
they're not actually rescuing people
that these are actually migrant boats
that are in effect doing something
illegal by bringing people across
borders that they're not supposed to and
that she herself never used any of her
money to go ahead and stop the boats or
anything like that yeah so two points on
that and I'm happy to have a discussion
about like who is a refugee and who is a
migrant and who gets to make that
decision and what is to be done about it
I want to separate that discussion from
content policy because it turns out
they're very different things content
policy is about manifests observable
behavior who is a migrant and who is a
refugee is a separate discussion that
actually has nothing to do with content
policy and then your other questions so
let's talk about that but your other
question specifically was about what was
it sir well for fun okay so our content
policy is divided into sections and
because this is where patreon is a
little bit different than other
platforms and we have to because we're
sending people money there's like three
sections of our content policy and sorry
if I'm getting really specific but I
mean this is that why we're do yeah plus
I you know people don't really share
their content policies in detail and I
don't want patreon to be one of those
companies I want to share our content
policy so the three main sections of the
content also you're like look you can't
do it or fund it on patreon that's the
first section that's like if you you
know everything from like hate speech to
you know horrible things child
pornography etc etc you can't do a fun
way let's let's pause there because the
hate speech thing I know the bells are
gonna be going off with my audience and
and me myself you how do you guys define
what hate speech is so it's defined in
great detail in the policy in terms of
like certain things that are allowed
certain things that are not allowed but
the point is there's this section of the
content policy that that specifically
mandates like the things that you can do
and can't do on patreon the platform
itself not like on Twitter but on
patreon the platform itself the second
section is you can't do it no matter
where you're doing it as long as you're
a crater on patreon in other words if
you are committing money laundering
somewhere else right but you're using
patreon to fund your weekly flute music
it doesn't matter that you're not using
your funds that you're making on patreon
for your money-laundering operation or
for your like if you've got a weapons
and bombs manufacturing facility like so
basically even if you're doing something
that has no connection but that's pretty
much an illegal activity is what you're
talking about
right because you're talking about bombs
and money laundering no it wouldn't no
it's not always law I think actually
most of things are probably probably
illegal like violent crime and there's
like property crime there's other things
in that section of the content policy
but but no there's there's a strict
separation between like law and content
policy those are also like different
discussions so it's not always illegal
things sometimes just things that we
don't want on patreon like pornography
totally legal totally okay if you want
to do that if you want to do it
elsewhere fine but can't do it on
patreon it's not because like it's bad
it's just we don't want pornography on
patreon that's not why this is the
mission of the company the mission of
companies to help creators yeah by the
way as I say on my show all the time and
I said at the top you guys are a private
company and you're allowed to do
whatever you want I didn't tried to be
very honest with my audience with that
now if that upsets them yeah they don't
they don't have to find me at all but
they certainly don't have to fund me on
patreon but so I'm not here to hammer
tell you've created these are the
policies you've created yeah yeah and at
the end of the day that's that's the way
we think about it which again is why we
distinguish between like law and and
like content policy they really are
different discussions the third section
of the content policy is like look even
if you're not doing it now you can't
ever have done these things and be a
crater on patreon and that's that's
things like terrorism and like you know
cybercrime etc yeah so I don't want to
whittle down too much with the migrant
vers immigrant there's a refugee thing
because a as you're saying this is a
separate issue you guys have your
policies that are not legal policies for
a nation total but I do think there's
something important here because because
what I'm hearing from a lot of these
people as I said is that these ships are
not doing exactly what it sounded like
you were saying in the video that they
actually are transporting intentionally
transporting migrants so in effect
they're doing something illegal and
Laura the defend Europe people are
actually defending the borders of Europe
so to speak um I'm just laying out the
case I'm not even saying whether I agree
with that their ad and I by the way it
sounds very all over the place with that
it sounds like some of them are actual
refugees some of them are migrants in
Saturday yeah but you're saying that
that is that completely irrelevant in
this it's totally irrelevant yeah it
actually has nothing to do with the
content polity decision and I can
explain why so let's say let's say a
person on patreon blocks an ambulance
okay I can't do that but then somebody
could say well that ambulance was on its
way to pick up person X who we know is a
convicted felon and did something
written and they lay out something
really horrible that that person has
done does that make it like let's say
it's a terrible person that that
ambulance was about to save let's say
they're about to save whoever is like
think of the worst person in the world
they're about to save a lot of the
people in the audience are thinking of
me right now okay so let's say like that
person was about to save jack conte
who's dying of a heart attack
Hitler's a little easier so you could
say okay well they've blocked the a
minutes well now you could say well the
ambulance was gonna pick up a terrible
person anyway so it's okay that they
blocked the ambulance in this particular
case no you can't say that because
because now patreon is suddenly in the
business of like investigating truths
based on opinions like it on this on
this migrant and refugee issue there are
papers published from universities and
and organizations on both sides of the
issue like okay how what percentage of
the people are actually you know like
legitimate refugees and then there's
also international law which says like
look anyone who's seeking asylum is
considered an asylum seeker and is given
like certain international rights etc
you if you start getting into those
issues it becomes an impossible
issue to tackle so but where we draw the
line as a private company it's like look
you can't you can't block an ambulance
no matter who that ambulance is going to
pick up so so to that point so I had
those videos that Lauren created been
exactly the same but had she just not
said to the it sounds like she said to
the captain to the ship or whoever was
in charge get in front get in front it's
a little unclear to me did she mean get
in front so that she could videotape
more or whatever I think so I think
there's a little bit of language stuff
there but our butter what is what you're
saying that had she not said any of that
any sort of direction to these people
but just been on board
you know recording what was happening
that this wouldn't have happened
that's right and by the way it's it is
very very clear to me if you watch the
video again she's not saying like get in
front of the ship so I can film or she
literally says get in front get in front
they have to stop like legally they have
to stop if we're in front of the boat
it's very clear like what she's what
she's saying what she's instructing the
boat operator to do if they're on the
side of the boat with signs waving and
screaming and yelling and exercising
their right to speak awesome you can
have a patreon page but you know and you
can do the same at the hospital you
stand outside hospitals say whatever you
want to say
we're not gonna stop you from doing that
there are other things that Lauren has
done that like hey we're not gonna stop
her from doing those things even though
like me personally I disagree with some
of those things but I'm not gonna stop
her from doing those things and in this
particular case like the second you
actually turn that speech into action
that's the line in our content policy so
yeah I mean literally it has to do with
the fact that she instructed the boat
operator to pull their boat in front of
theirs yeah so I want to get a little
more into the speech and action thing
because obviously that goes to the heart
of a lot of what we talk about here when
you guys were talking about manifest
observable behavior did you realize that
the acronym for it was mob no I did not
realize that observable babe but I so
when that came to my mind I thought
there is an element of this that feels a
little bit like mob rule to me which is
that there are certain things that like
I'm pretty sure that regardless of your
own political opinion you admit you
would admit that you know tech companies
and Silicon Valley in San Francisco know
that it leans pretty far left it leans
pretty far too aggressive and all that
and I think one of the reasons that
patreon is so successful is that you
guys have become the sort of refuge for
a lot of the people that feel like we're
being treated unfairly on those things
where my videos don't get monetized on
YouTube they're unclear about the
algorithm you know I see people being
subscribed all the time all that and I
think partly what a lot of your creators
are fearing now is that mob rule mob
meaning a big group of people but also
this acronym here will just sort of kick
in that eventually the that Lauren
although this may be completely within
the lines of what you guys have set out
that it will just eventually get to a
place where anyone who's doing anything
it'll just get kicked up enough and that
you'll just be under pressure sort of
that the the dam has broke already
I think that's a big fear here no I just
completely disagree at that and I
anybody who's watching who's worried
about that
yeah we're just it's a different system
the reason this is happening on these
other platforms is because of pressure
from advertisers right all of their
dollars are coming from advertisers and
advertisers are very picky
around what
of content they want to run their ads
against when you have write in all these
other media companies the stakeholders
are viewer fan employee investor
shareholder advertiser that adding an
advertiser to that list of stakeholders
completely changes the nuance and
organization of the ecosystem and it
changes the the stakes that are of the
ecosystem and it changes the content
itself unfortunately that's one of the
things that patreon is fighting like I
hate the fact that literally my videos
on YouTube or somebody who has nothing
to do with my relationship with my fans
or the platform itself gets to like it
gets to decide whether or not I make
money you know on these videos or not
that sucks for me
I hate that and so we have completely
removed advertisers from the model
itself right advertisers are not
stakeholders in the patreon ecosystem if
they're scared about this particular
type of content of that particular type
of code it doesn't matter like they can
pull their ads on YouTube they have zero
effect on the content on patreon that's
really important to us and it'll stay
that way why not just let everyone use
the platform for whatever they want and
if in a case that something's illegal
let the legal system deal with it I've
heard that from a lot of people and
there is a huge piece of me that sort of
agrees with that that just it's a
platform anyone can do it the second you
cross a legal line it's no longer a
patreon issue it's now a legal issue
yeah you're saying why isn't content
policy just law why have content policy
at all
well well for you for you in this case
why not just let the policy be we let
anyone that's creating be here yeah the
second you do something that is actually
illegal yeah well now it's not it's not
within our purview anymore it's now to
something much bigger than us totally so
yeah the the answer that question is
again I think relatively simple but then
if you dive into it it's not the answer
is patreon has a mission right we we
have a purpose for existing
law has a mission to laws purpose is
different than patreon purpose and so we
need a different set of rules to govern
our omission and to describe and to
propel our mission forward and so we've
developed a set of rules that propel our
mission and again it's not that it's
counter to law it's literally just like
a little bit you know it's a little bit
of a different direction
like for example pornography I don't
want porn on patreon and again it's not
that like I think it porn should be
illegal or I don't think people should
be looking at porn it's just that that's
not patreon mission and so if we have
porn on patreon it changes the ego it
changes the entire ecosystem right
people start to think of patreon as a
porn site if there's too much porn on
patreon and then suddenly folks like you
and others think I don't want to use
patreon it's a porn site and that hurts
our mission right because we start
turning away the kinds of craters that
we want to be on the platform so it
turns out like you have to have some set
of rules to govern your ecosystem that
are effectively a model of your mission
your purpose for existence yeah and
these are the rules that describe the
mission that we have do you think that
there's some sort of slippery slope
aspect to this words and action thing
because it's one of the things that I've
been talking about for a while here
which is that if you keep labeling
everyone Nazis and then you're okay with
punching Nazis that man can blow up a
Nazis car like we've created something
here and I say this because I know for
many of the people that I've had on this
show the Southern Poverty Law Center for
example has listed people that I'm now
friends with him know well like ayaan
Hirsi Ali and Maajid Nawaz and Brigitte
Gabriel anti Muslim extremists these
people could not be from Majin himself
as Muslim ayaan was born Muslim I mean
these people could not be anything
further from that but I could see a
situation where one of them perhaps
would try to get on patreon your team
would do a little digging and go well
they did say this and then there was
some violence not that they called
directly for bombs but that slippery
slope part of that how cognizant
are you of that so we're not gonna look
at what the press says right we're not
gonna look at them are not at all
because there were a couple of pretty
terrible articles written about me that
talked about patreon as well Mother
Jones wrote a really awful libelous
piece about me
further to the right than Breitbart or
something to her Spiegel and they by the
way in both the cases mentioned patreon
yeah so you're saying that stuff has
nothing to do whether it gets across
your desk or not has nothing to do with
any of that's not in our content policy
like what one particular paper says
about a person or someone's opinion
about a person not in our content policy
you can't scale a system based on other
people's opinions about people on your
platform that would be ineffective and
just bad content policy so no I don't
care who says what about you or anyone
else we care what you do right we care
what the behaviors are that are or not
against the content policy and by the
way gosh one thing I feel like I just
have to say I want to like send this bit
like that's why you're here right most
create like creators watching us you
just don't have to worry about this [ __ ]
you just don't have to worry about it
like people like you and people most
people who are like engaging and healthy
dialogue and talking about tough issues
like this is just not something that
concerns most creators and it like kills
me a little bit that there's this fear
you know one of the things Sam Harris
said in in in the podcast where he
talked about leaving patreon was like
this is there's this wave of deep
platforming and I just kills me that
there is that fear there and it doesn't
have to be there for most creators so I
think the issue is that we for those
that for so many of us who I referenced
earlier who have come to patreon as a
refuge yeah I'm this nonsense yeah we're
the same people who have been calling
out all of this craziness on campuses
all of this silencing of dissent all of
this firing people over joke and all of
this other nonsense so I think that's
why if in your opinion the the fear is
overblown from where I sit it's very
much rational because we were all like
look I've built
in my home right now I can afford to do
this and this studio that when you
walked in you're very impressed by yeah
I can do this because of the platform
you created yeah so that's why this is
to me this is the most in a certain way
this is the most personal interview that
I've ever done in an odd way sorry I
didn't mean to suggest that the fear is
overblown the fear is legitimate and
real what kills me about it is that
people are starting it like that Sam was
worried about one of the questions you
asked me on the phone was like hey if I
bring someone on the show that you guys
don't agree with like is my show at risk
that's what kills me cuz like the the
answer is like a resounding no your show
is not at risk like talking about issues
again I can't I can't stress how
important that is the difference between
pulling your ship in front of another
ship and what we're doing here in this
room or what you do with any person
who's of any particular opinion in this
room like that is a very different
behavior so for the record you did say
to me I just wanted so that this is out
on YouTube forever you said to me my
chance my channel not to make it about
me but I gather that my channel has 0%
chance of being deleted I think you said
something very similar to my friend
Colin Moriarty and I suspect you
probably said it to a couple people
other people that I don't know if your
content is anything like the content
that that you have been doing so far
it's not gonna get deleted it's just a
lot so you have to worry about so what
if I brought loner and back on the show
next great
you should bring Lauren back on the show
like you should have healthy dialogue
with people about this right I mean
anything less would be crazy yeah yeah
yeah I mean I'm with you on that but I
but so you can understand why it's a
legit fear though because of how we sort
of all got here the end the D
platforming and all that that now we're
this was the first time where we saw D
platforming on the thing that we've all
went to yeah because of the platforming
I totally understand how it's legit fear
I just I guess what I was trying to
express was that I I don't like that
that fear is associated with patreon
because at the end of the day like we
just have a very different we have a
much higher tolerance of stuff
we don't have advertisers and that makes
it just makes such a big difference
that's why we have been able to do what
we do yeah do you think there's some
sort of inherent risk though about
partly what we do with our money once we
put that money into action so for
example if I was funding gay people
getting out of Saudi Arabia let's say
which I suspect would probably be
something that you jack conte were
probably before or I was funding you
know free speech activists and bloggers
in Bangladesh or something
now that's an action that I'd be putting
using the money that I created here you
would have I think in those two cases
you would be for those actions so it
wouldn't be a problem but there could be
a situation I can't think of one off the
top of my head that I might want to put
money behind something that you you
wouldn't be thrilled with yeah so I it's
too I don't mean I mean you as the
company I don't mean sure sure no it's
it's a I love to talk about examples but
when we're going to talk about examples
we have to be like ultra specific to
like really figure out if this is
something that like is or isn't against
the content policy right like because
because the kind of policy is long
there's a lot of things so just to
whittle it down a little bit let's use
the example if I was funding or helping
somehow or you know becoming an activist
in an organization that was helping gay
people get out of Saudi Arabia yeah
let's use that one it's just the
straight-up example well I would say
have you done any of the things in our
content policy that are against the
content policy and if you haven't then
you can keep doing it right but what if
those organizations we're also doing
anti-government activities in Saudi
Arabia the point that I'm trying to get
to is that it's hard to at some point
you can widdle everything down to you
know well the US has allies with Saudi
Arabia are you funding dissent in the
Saudi Arabian government and but see no
that right but that's why we base
everything on manifests observable
behavior so we don't have to like
because otherwise you literally can't
deal with those sorts of issues unless
you have the tweet from the person that
says you know I'm gonna bomb this
building in order to accomplish my
mission or whatever then yeah then we
can't then we've got a credible threat
and
we take action but like if somebody is
not breaking the content policy then it
doesn't matter what you're trying to do
like you can of course you can take
action as long as none of those actions
are against things that are in the
condom policy sorry I sound a little bit
like I'm a broken record here it's just
that's why you have really clear spelled
out content policy that's based on
behavior not on like ideology or or
other things like that yeah getting away
from patreon for shares to sex so that
you don't have to say content policy
mm-hmm
can you just talk to me a little bit
about what you feel like the general
culture is in Silicon Valley and all
that around this stuff like I suspect
you're probably gonna get some hate from
CEOs some who you don't even know just
for doing this because that culture as I
said before a lack of transparency
yeah the inability to connect with any
of these people is again another reason
why we all came to patreon yeah I don't
think I'm gonna get hate from CEOs I
think the one thing that I actually
really appreciate about the culture in
Silicon Valley is despite the fact that
I think people could do more to be
transparent a lot more to be transparent
with communities and users people are
very transparent with each other there's
a lot of sharing a lot of discussion and
dialogue CEOs are constantly helping
each other out so I will like frequently
call up other CEOs and ask them
questions I've you know and it's amazing
it's so different than because right
before this I was in the music industry
for ten years like you are alone on an
island in the music industry like I felt
I felt isolated from other folks and
like if you want to figure out how much
do you pay a guitar player when you go
on tour with them you know like what's
there what's a what's a good weekly rate
to pay a guitar player it's freaking
tough to answer that question if you're
an independent musician I mean you got a
call a lot of people there's no data
it's not organized if you want to figure
out you know how much do you pay this
kind of employer whatever a designer an
engineer that has like three years of
experience and his work at these
companies there are like so many public
databases that organized compet
four employees and it becomes actually a
very solvable problem to figure out how
much do you pay employees and that has
to do with companies just being willing
and open to share with each other so I'd
say like one of the main things about
the culture is discussion so for that
reason like I do not think I'm going to
get a lot of hate from CEOs I think
people will like talk about this and
it'll just be a you know it'll be
something that people like discuss and
share with each other so alright we got
away from patreon specifically for a
second I was giving you I was giving you
a minute there ya go
macroline so for the people that get
what you're saying about manifest
adorable behavior yeah
they get what I'm saying about sort of
the slippery slope of all of this yeah I
think there's going to be a certain
amount of people that no matter what you
say are gonna say wait the dam broke
here now he one day you're going to get
protested by a certain amount of people
you know you mean they're gonna start
looking at your creators whether they've
done anything or not but you have I
can't even think of anyone off the top
of my head or they could they could go
look he's got it yeah got Rubin on yeah
Colin on he was in hot water for some
stuff one for a tweet he sent blah blah
blah that we've already seen that these
guys kind of came so you're giving me
absolute assurances that it's simply
about that and no more that the stake is
in the in the ground and this is the
place that you guys won't move from we
have our content policy as it stands now
I think it's a good rigorous solid
content policy personally I spent like
two months building this policy with an
expert who had literally scaled a trust
and safety team to like a massive
operation with lots of people working on
this stuff and literally was like
training computers on how to
automatically identify some awful things
that are like should not be okay child
pornography etc and was literally of
like training algorithms to identify
this kind of stuff this person was an
absolute expert in content policy I feel
really really good about this policy I
think like anything content policy is
going to change and adopt over time so
what I'm not going to say is like hey
policy is going to be exactly the same
five years from now that's just not true
what I can say is that like I think you
know personally I want to build like a
platform I want patreon to be to be a
you know a company that that values free
speech that values creators that wants
to pay creators that wants to put people
like in that mission that wants to put
people in that world where they're
making money and where they can buy a
studio like this that's what's important
to me and again like it comes down to
like the things that you're doing if
you're gonna take action that's gonna
like hurt a person that we're just not
going to be okay with that so one of the
things that you addressed in the video
that you put up is that the way you guys
went about doing this may have been a
little sloppy or may perhaps not the
best way of doing it yeah that you
deleted her channel there was no chance
of recourse or anything like that yeah
so you are gonna change that correct oh
yeah yeah I I that was not good and like
all I'm fine saying that I mean I think
you know part of part of doing this is
like acknowledging when you've made a
mistake it wasn't a good email that we
sent her that's not the kind of company
that we want to be it's not the company
that I want to build I feel bad about
that
did no one think that if this was
completely objectable and you know
completely the reverse of what your TOS
is that still she should at least get a
chance or did that would that even
discussed beforehand so at the end of
the day it comes down to like systems
design every system is gonna is gonna
have certain failure points that's what
we saw here it's not yeah it's it would
be wrong to say that there's like a
person who was like ah we need to stick
it to somebody right like that's just
not what happened I think it's easy to
think that that's what's happened you
know happen from the outside but you
know from the inside what happened was
you know we had these systems we had
these procedures we went through a
system and it ain't going through that
we realized gosh this was not the right
way to do it and so we're gonna change
the system we're gonna build like an
appeals process we're gonna build like a
warning system we're gonna invest in
external comms with creators because
that's super important it builds trust
with
community and yeah we didn't do a good
job there I feel bad about that time
like brainy that's there yeah so like by
the end of the year we're gonna be
doubling the size of the trust and
safety team that's gonna allow us to do
things like invest in the appeals
process etc so would Lauren herself be
allowed to appeal what happened at this
point gosh I hadn't thought about that
we don't have the appeal system in place
if she wanted to appeal if she wanted to
be like hey this isn't fair
persley yeah like great we would look at
it again I don't think there's anything
that we missed if there's new evidence
we'd be happy to look at it right well
let's say just right now while if she
accepted that okay by the end of the
year they're gonna take care of this
stuff mm-hmm but in the meantime since
she happens to be the person that's
going through this right now if she was
to contact you directly or the team or
whatever and say you know what I hear
what you're saying about these specific
videos I will take these videos down and
I won't do that again is there any
chance that there would be a special
conversation about her cuz that's the
one that this is really all about I
guess is what I'm saying if she wanted
to talk to me personally and talk about
the stuff of course I would do that of
course I would i i'm i got the padding
you don't publicly but i'm happy to
facilitate it no it's fine i think one
of the worse things that's like going on
right now is people not talking to each
other i don't want to be one of those
people that's not talking to each other
about this kind of stuff if we miss
something or if there's something
obviously wrong i want to know about it
i want it to be fair and that's
important to me is there any type of
person right now that would set bells
off just by setting up a patreon account
so the the easiest example i can give
you is if milo innopolis today was like
alright I'm jumping on patreon is there
an inherent problem there so there are
lots of people that would set bells off
by setting up patreon pages terrorists
money launderers right so room ronster
using the the strictly illegal people up
to illegal activities removing people
hmm somebody that that happens to be
controversial someone who expect from
looking at your Twitter that you
probably are not a big fan of let's say
someone like milo with that set off any
bells internally as to can we even go up
because the same people that really
don't like Lauren yeah or the same
people that like Lauren like Milo
obviously yeah again what I would say is
and see here's the other thing I think
people don't understand about these
sorts this isn't I don't this is not my
job right I don't do our content policy
her team does our content policy so if
there were here's what I would say if
there were lots of incoming reports they
would look at a bunch of evidence they'd
make a determination and they'd make a
decision one way or the other after we
like investigated it thoroughly
I don't know and and I I'd like to sit
here and be able to say I know all the
answers I have everything but the truth
is I don't we have to look at it see if
there's any manifests observable
behavior that's against the content
policy god I feel like saying that I
like kind of funny about a guy who's
really an artist in a musician talking
about Terms of Service that's quite a
karmic thing you did there yeah well
it's been it's been a few years of
growing for me so the other page that
you took down a couple days after this
was this it's going down yeah page which
is connected to either directly or
loosely with an tyfa yeah were you guys
so first of a lot of people were saying
to me you see what they did there they
took Lauren down and now they're just
throwing us a bone by taking that one
down right now I would argue that's not
really throwing anyone bone because
having more things taken off the
platform isn't what I personally would
want obviously it's not up to me yep
were these things happening in
conjunction was it a response where you
were just trying to save face or
whatever else so I actually personally
looked into this because it was
important to me I personally looked in
this whole thing but that very issue in
particular
turns out we that page was in the queue
in the trust and safety queue before we
even took down Lauren's page
so like the the people saying that like
oh this is just a response and they're
just trying to cover their ass and blah
blah blah
it's actually just not sure when you say
the queue you mean the queue meeting to
take down or the queue to be looked at
like a trust and safety evaluation queue
where it's like oh this is we looked at
now there's not necessarily to be taken
oh yeah well yeah to be reviewed yeah
yeah yeah but the thing is the team what
do we have like right now there's about
three people on the team right so
there's they have a queue of pages it is
very often like if happens
all the time where they'll like look at
a page and then they'll look at another
page and look at another page we'll take
down pages you know two weeks three
weeks apart like we don't batch pages
altogether that are like politically you
know opposing and take them down at the
same time to like seem like we're being
fair like that's not how we do things we
take them down in an order so folks who
are saying that like oh we happen to
take this page down right at the right
moment that means if they're just trying
to cover their ass it's just not true
yeah all right so you know what I think
we should do this so I told the audience
that we were gonna do a Q&A via patreon
and super chat I want to get to that I
also know that you have to get back you
you agreed to do this in basically no
time yeah literally you didn't pause
when I asked you to do this yeah my own
ins to know that because that is not
something that happens often it
basically never happens
yeah so we're gonna take literally a
30-second break and then we're gonna
jump into audience questions but so the
last thing I want to ask you before that
though is if you were what would be your
last pitch for the for the 200 so people
that have canceled my page
so I'm taking a brunt to this I mean I
took a financial and now it's over
$1,000 a month as I said we made some of
that back on PayPal it's irrelevant to
the purposes of this conversation it's
completely irrelevant yeah but for those
people you can I don't know if you know
what your internal numbers are and
you're sure you're not allowed to share
them anyway but for the people that
you've now lost that you want to get
back what would be your closing
statement and why you think you did the
right thing and why they can have their
trust put back in patreon then we'll
take a quick break and then we'll get to
there audience question yeah I just say
that and this is just like a matter of
belief like if you don't believe us fine
you'd but this isn't for the people like
over here who don't believe us this is
for the people who like who maybe think
that some people in the world are good
we are so rigorous and thoughtful about
this kind of stuff we had the whole
executive team looking at this we had we
had you know the entire trust and safety
team stringing other tons and tons of
evidence we spent a lot of hours on this
we will continue to be extra rigorous
extra thoughtful extra careful around
these issues I think we are so much more
careful and thoughtful than other
companies
dealing with these issues and certainly
then people I think give us credit for
based on some of the comments about us
just doing things on a whim
so I guess my pitch would be like look
there's a lot of smart people that are
thinking very very hard about this and
making good thoughtful rigorous
evidence-based decisions that's that's
it I mean at the end of the day like you
know it comes down to like is this
something that you you know is this
something where you're just you know you
you you can't see it you can't agree you
can't trust you assume people are bad or
is this something where you actually
think like look people are working hard
to try and make this really fair and I
think that's what I can tell you we are
working very very hard to try and make
this fair yeah and I would be remiss if
I had you sitting here and I was able to
look you in the eyes and didn't say that
I want this to work yeah as badly as you
want this work I want this work this
having paid the thing that you created
literally changed my life you're sitting
in evidence of that yeah so I want this
to work it's why I wanted to have this
conversation as I said to you right
before we started some people are gonna
be more angry me for whatever reason
some people will be more angry at you
and that's all just it is what it is
yeah but I hope we've given them a
little bit of taste of that things are
kind of complex and and we'll go from
there
but before I even bother saying anything
else we're gonna take literally a
30-second break okay
I love you fill your water okay all
right 30-second break I'm gonna refill
Jack's water and then patreon questions
which we've already got roughly four
billion of them and we'll jump into
super chat as well 30 seconds I know why
you should say a minute it takes 3
minutes 30 seconds
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys we're back I think we took
45 seconds there sorry about that I'll
make the 15 seconds up to you alright
here we go we have roughly four zillion
questions we'll start with super chat
quick I think you addressed this but
maybe there's something you can pin down
a little closer did hope not hate lobby
patreon or you or you lying or is hope
not hate lying
you said shareholders have no influence
on content hope not hate is taking
credit for successfully lobbying you
guys so I did see some tweets I guess by
someone from hope not hate implying that
they did have something to do with this
are you saying that's not the case just
just to know an absolute whittle down
answer on that no here's here's what
I'll say
everyone lobbies on these decisions we
don't proactively police the community
right the reason that a page gets taken
down is because we get reports through
an official reporting system that leads
us to take down a page so if they sent
in a report then we evaluated their
report like we evaluated probably so
their numbers report I actually don't
know yeah I don't know they may have
okay yeah but but I I honestly don't
know but if they did then we'd evaluate
that report like we evaluate the hundred
other reports that came in about that
account all right so from patreon and I
think some of these are gonna be a
little bit repetitive but they might be
at least give you a chance to UM you
know specify a couple crazy a question
about transparency will you in the
future be more upfront with providing
the evidence behind your decisions as
well as allowing the creator that you're
looking at to voice their own defense so
I think we know the answer to the voice
there are defense because you will put
in this this policy of allowing them to
discuss it but what about being
transparent about laying out the case
yeah for for the patrons yeah totally so
yes we're going to do that for the
patron side I actually don't I don't
know what our policy is going to be
there for the crater side when we send
an email to the crater we're going to
explain the very specific evidence
because I think they deserve to know do
we want to make that public I think in
this particular case I made a video
talking about what the evidence was I
don't think we're gonna be doing that
every time it's just not scalable we
can't do something like that but I do
think we have to do a better job of
explaining like why a particular crane
got taken down that's super-important
okay I'm glad someone asked this on
patreon because I think it's a better
version of the question that I asked you
so I asked you about well what if I was
helping you know get gay people out of
Saudi Arabia we don't sure you would
probably agree is okay and that most
people would agree with but this but
this is I think a more specific point
which is if a patreon creator spends the
funds promoting free speech and
democracy in China and that activity is
illegal in China would patreon de
platform the Creator so I think that's
that's actually a better way of phrasing
the question mm-hmm
in other words if you've no so so here's
what I would say if you violate a law in
a in a in a country that is not the
United States but you violate a local
law somewhere else I actually don't
think we have anything in our content
policy about that right now
maybe we should but we taught right so
yeah violating local laws in in in
international territories I think when
we start internationalizing more and we
we change currencies and we we allow for
localization of language and stuff like
that we'll probably have to start
getting into those sorts of issues but
right now I don't think there's anything
in our content policy about violating
local laws so basically if I want to
start funding democracy in China I
better do it quick because real I mean
the truth is that once you guys start
having those conversations that's where
the lawyers get involved then there are
connections I mean I think the other
fear that a lot of my doin's audience
has is that there are so many
connections these days between
politicians and the heads of all of
these companies and I think that that's
part of the fear yeah yeah I mean what
can I say I you know that certainly
exists although I don't think it really
is as as political as a lot of people
think I I think honestly it comes down
to like advertising and making sure that
the platforms when YouTube makes a
decision to to D monetize a particular
video I think that sucks
and I'm sad that the ecosystem works
that way if you look at actually what
happened to to YouTube advertisers
pulled out right because they didn't
want their ads against a particular type
of con
YouTube had their hand forced at that
point to basically make the system more
friendly to advertisers which
unfortunately means more do monetization
for creators but it's a that's not a
political issue that's not because they
have ties to this particular government
or that particular politician it's
because advertisers are paying them and
responsible for most their revenue and
don't want their ads run against those
videos I just think that that strongly
misguided but I see what your what's
your point
what's your unit well that is strongly
misguided because a first up on YouTube
especially no one associates the ad with
an endorsement of the content ever it's
just never happened but then even beyond
just the general you know there's less
inventory so I understand that at a
business level but we do videos where we
talk about free speech and we talked
about dissent or religion and things
like that those those videos it's not
that they're being D monetized they're
not even getting monetized in the first
place so there's several problems there
but I know you're not a representative
but but what I'm what I'm saying is like
if the advertisers want to pull out they
pull out right regardless of like if
it's a good decision or not regardless
of whether consumers associate the ad
with the video or not
advertisers are pulling out again I
think that has to do with the
stakeholders an ecosystem and bad design
like it's just advertising is a bad way
to get creators paid it just doesn't do
a good job from patreon have you reached
out to sam harris and if so what was his
response i have reached out to sam
harris we talked for a little while
i don't know if he wants me to talk
publicly about what he said to me but i
felt a lot better after our conversation
but yeah i would feel weird about
putting that conversation on the record
because the expectation was that it was
a private conversation okay yeah
from super chat does Jack know why the
right-wing cartoonist Emily forgive me
if I'm pronouncing her last name wrong
you kiss his account was removed a long
time ago she's not an activist so it was
based on hate speech and racism is that
not a political decision I don't know
why our account was removed I could look
into it but yeah I know who she is I
don't know who she is okay all right I
can't ask you to come in and something
that you don't know
Tifa has crossed the line multiple times
from speech to aggression will you take
steps in their pages too as far as said
to me during the break as far as you
know there are no anti five pages on
patreon right now I know I don't know of
them I know we took down it's going down
if there are other pages I'm not aware
of them right now but if there were
other pages that exist anti five pages
that exist right now you they would be
removed again it depends on what they've
done if they did something like it's
going down did where they publish an
article that explains how to pour
concrete over railroad tracks and then
yes okay yeah why was eight Chan removed
from patreon hmm yeah
woof we're gonna get into some stuff
here they were allowing like the
distribution of child pornography on
their servers that's it not okay I mean
actually yeah that's illegal and against
our content policy question project the
complaint about these non-government
ships is that they are rescuing people
and taking them over to Italy it's a
clear loophole and immigration is there
any acknowledgement that this is what
the groups who are opposing not
specifically the rescuing so that's sort
of where we started this whole thing out
that there yeah that the very issue here
seems to be depending on which way you
look at it either these ships or
rescuing people or they're actually
taking part in something that's illegal
in the first place yeah so again I'm
gonna separate content policy from
discussions of like who is and is not a
refugee if you want to have that
discussion again happy to do it I would
say for that particular issue there are
international laws around who is and
isn't a refugee it's in the 1951 Refugee
Convention that like over a hundred and
forty five countries have entered into
and it's a legally binding international
document I think one of the difficulties
with that document is it doesn't layout
accountability procedures around it so
if you violate the laws in this treaty
nothing happens to you which is kind of
a bad system in and of itself
but yeah the people who are saying like
oh these people are not refugees they're
immigrants you know technically there's
due process to decide who is who
and so these international conventions
lay out what that due process is and you
know you there's a you know if you wish
literally if you wish to be determined
if you wish to have your status
determine as a refugee then you're
guaranteed certain rights as an asylum
seeker but again we're talking about law
here
not content yeah I don't want to go you
know I think we've gone foreign debt
down that rabbit hole because regardless
if that's not for all of those things
have very little to do with Lauren's
account it's a separate issue and in it
yes right I think we can only go that
far yeah so I had a whole bunch of
people asking about this sort of thing
this is from super chat black lives
matter has multiple or has blocked
multiple ambulances and also use
utilized explosives during riots
why does Jack allow an Tifa and other
designated domestic terror organizations
to raise money on spyler so there's
there's a little disconnect there
because we've already done the anti
fraud thing black lives matter is not a
domestic terror organization there's a
certain sect of people that want it to
be labeled it's oh but what about the
the portion of black lives matter that
absolutely has talked about using
violence in some case use violence and I
mean people can google it pretty pretty
easily so so here's the things I know
you guys have met with the Rae and all
that here's the thing with organizations
where people people people assume and I
think wrongfully so like anyone on
patreon is allowed to interview or
express support or talk about or you
you're allowed to talk right we're not
going to stop you from talking we're not
going to stop you from interviewing
anybody on this show but as soon as you
put up a page and raise money to do bad
things that are against the content
policy that's when we'll take your page
down so I would say to that person like
send us the page that is violating our
content policy send us the page that
that you think like and send us the
tweet the screenshot from that
particular crater who did that
particular wrong thing but
you're gonna get into like this
organization this person interviewed
them and and then that person
interviewed this person and tied their
support to Bob it's like send us the
behavior like unless you're very clear
with what the behavior is and then it
just doesn't work you have to be ultra
ultra specific with content is it clear
if there was a black lives matter page
that absolutely was calling for violence
or do anything close to what IgD was
doing or any of that they would be under
the same type of scrutiny of course okay
okay here's an interesting one this is
from patreon cannabis is illegal
according to federal law are those who
use have used or advocate the use of
cannabis or other schedule 1 substances
allowed on patreon if yes what felony
behavior is allowable and what not
that's a good one it's a good one that's
a good one
again I just feel like I'm repeating
myself there's a difference between law
and content policy right so if you smoke
pot and you're a creator that's not
against our content policy what if you
were smoking pot on camera so now you're
doing an action that is federally
illegal yeah I mean even right now I
have a medical marijuana thing lower a
little lower back pain yeah if I was
smoking pot right now on camera which
would be absolutely legal in the state
of California it's federally illegal but
again canta policy is not federal law
right we have different we have
different of different mission different
guidelines than the law so no I don't
think there's anything in our content
all sea about smoking pot on camera
right but so in this case you would
allow for a federally illegal behavior
to be done as part of the content that's
being created I think we would yeah yeah
I mean this is not easy I got yeah I got
you yeah I can see it in you it's not
easy yeah I I don't I don't think that's
against our policy i it's not like
against the mission of the company no I
think it'd be fine not I think it is
fine there are many examples of creators
smoking pot that we would allow on
patreon
this sort of gets the sign that I have
that I brought up before but maybe we
can get a little a little whittled dear
Jack do you know that a lot of people
live in a climate of fear when it comes
to the left and seeing this take down
has made them feel more unsafe than ever
that it doesn't matter what you do the
platforms will come after you so that's
what I'm saying we're a lot that's one
of the reasons I love patreon yeah this
is the refuge for these people that are
upset with a lot of these other things
so that sort of guess what I was saying
about that in a way now the the first
dam has been broken here and I think a
lot of people are just gonna sort of
hold that against you
regardless yeah yeah I'm aware that
there's fear and I think that we talked
about that half hour ago I think it
sucks that there's that fear I think
it's legitimate there's a lot of there's
a lot of D monetization that's happening
right now there and I think the the
pains of the advertising ecosystem are
certain to become exceptionally clear
but again I think the thing that makes
patreon different is we don't have the
advertiser in the as a stakeholder in
the ecosystem that makes our job a lot
easier because that's one less person
that we have to worry about making happy
all right our revenue isn't coming from
advertisers is coming from consumers
that just makes this easier and and
safer and wider this is from super chat
just as an aside to what Jack had said
there's a lot of people who use patreon
and create explicit or implied
pornographic content such as Meg Turney
Jessica Aguirre and Sara Underwood these
are three of some of the largest
creators on the site so I don't know who
those three people are I'm guessing you
probably do I'm not familiar with their
content again if so we define porn very
very specifically on patreon you can
imagine how much detail I went into to
write this document with with this
person way more detail than I ever
wanted to go into to define what is the
difference between porn and art from a
high level I would say if it's rated R
it's okay like we won't deal we won't do
pornographic films but you can make
r-rated content where there's you know
we're an arts company you can take a
nude picture of somebody you can draw a
nude painting but on Instagram you can't
do that right they'll allow flagging of
content
there's breasts or something in the
content but that's fine on patreon can
you ask Jack about sargon of akkad and
why he was looked at but our Nita Anita
sarkeesian was not looking to for her
providing false information about him so
I'm not sure what that one's about I
don't know about that either again with
these I think a lot of the questions
that we're starting to get a lot of the
questions that that we've gotten so far
are like is does this violate your
policy does that violate your policy and
I understand that people really want
specificity over that which is one of
the reasons that like the trust and
safety team is going to work very hard
to make our policy a lot more clear and
transparent to the community for those
particular questions does this violate
your policy does that violate your
policy you can't you literally can't
answer those questions without getting
ultra ultra specific in order to answer
that question
our team builds like 10 page reports
about whether or not there's a policy
violation and it requires just so much
evidence and rigor and detail so like a
question that's asked in one sentence
you you literally can't get to the
bottom of it
so what about the manifest observable
behavior of groups like black lives
matter their protests have blocked busy
streets in major cities many times how
many ambulances have they stopped from
getting to where they needed to go so
we've addressed black lives matter but I
think that that's that's a good point
that we've consistently seen this as
part of the protest ambulances are
blocked protesting in the middle of a
public street is actually illegal you
may be for it but it actually is illegal
so what happens to any of these offshoot
patrons that pop up that are associated
with them yeah so we had a we actually
had a discussion about this at the at
the office because it's a it's a
important nuanced question let's say you
hold a protest and it's beauty
you know you're protesting whatever you
don't agree with and you're in the
street and a lot of people show up and
the protest gets organized and and it
becomes a thing and at that protest
somebody it's just right there's a lot
of people there and somebody trips and
falls and bashes their head open and
dies are we gonna hold you responsible
as it creator for that is that a
violation of our content policy no it's
not we had a discussion about that for a
quite a long time but basically our
thought was like look while you are
exercising your right to free speech and
you were doing what is okay
according to the guidelines and
according to the law something bad
happened but but in cases where they
know that they're putting people out in
the middle of street which is illegal or
they're stopping other parades from you
know they're stopping the gay pride
parade in Toronto until they sign you
know basically extorting them until they
sign their you know Charter on we're
gonna you know go with you on all these
specific points that's a little
different than someone accidentally
falling and yeah again I'm not familiar
with the situation like if if you were
to to you know show a creator who had
pulled their car in front of an
ambulance that creator right not like a
creator who had interviewed an
organization who did something like that
but if the creator themselves pulled
their car in front of an ambulance we
would take that crater down no matter
what organization they are part of so on
the speech verge verse action part yeah
if you had a creator who was saying okay
I'm going to this event one of the
things you can do is pull your car in
front of a police car
to be there now this is all this this
person just said it they didn't actually
do it do you make a distinction there so
we do which is the reason we took down
the IgD page right that wasn't a case of
them I'm pretty sure they didn't
actually themselves pour concrete over
railroad tracks they published an
article about how to do this if you're
advocating for violent you know crime or
whatever that's also not okay so yeah we
do make a distinction between like for
instance you can't on patreon you can't
write Daxing is not okay
you can't talk somebody which is another
reason we took down IgD but you also
can't go to your audience and say hey
folks go find this person's home address
and publish it all over the Internet you
can't do that so so yeah we do make a
distinction like what you can tell the
people to do and what you can do
yourselves that that's all
policy yeah all right I know you have a
heart out so we're just gonna do two
more and then you you've survived Craig
hi jack how does patreon define a quote
attack on someone I'm getting this from
your community guidelines regarding hate
speech so this is a good question cuz
again it gets to just this specificity
I'm all of these words
yeah and that's why why I don't like the
phrase hate speech because what's a one
man's free speech is another man's hate
speech so how do you defined it I don't
know how we define attack I'd have to
pull up our content policy I know that
we distinguish between like a personal
person and a public person so you can
say certain things about a president or
a politician that you can't say about a
particular individual we have like a
bullying policy in our in our in our
guidelines you can't like bully a
private person and that's defined I'd
actually don't know how that's defined
off the top of my head but we have
definitions for these types of things
and we yeah we do we do draw some
important distinctions there like you
know if you want to say whatever you
want about Trump or about Obama you can
say way more about those folks than you
can say about you know your classmate in
school yeah all right final question why
should people keep supporting creators
like me on patreon gosh all right it
sucks that it's 2017 and you've got
creators with millions of fans getting
paid a few hundred bucks a month that
sucks
I still can't believe the internet has
made it this far and you got a person
who's improving the lives of a million
people and getting 20,000 people a month
reading their blog or or watching their
videos or reading their articles and
that person gets paid 300 bucks a month
in ad revenue that like makes my heart
hurt I can't believe that we've allowed
this to happen there's like systemic
abuse of creative people is
moralizing to me and there are 80 people
in San Francisco who get up every
morning and want to change that want to
fix that and people in the world can
change that and they can fix that by
supporting creators on patreon by giving
10 bucks a month five bucks a month to
do a little part and to to change the
way the system works so yeah do it
because it's the right thing to do
because the world would suck without
creators and because you know while art
is now free while videos are free while
music is free and it's not a question
anymore right now creators aren't free
right this studio isn't free it's so
important that people realize that and
and take their part to change that yeah
well I appreciate you coming in I know
making those calls on Thursday probably
was not easy for you I think I was one
of the first ones because we were first
thing in the morning mm-hmm and and as I
said at the beginning and I think it's
worth repeating you did not pause when I
said will you come on the show I think
you said gosh I'd love to yeah without
even pausing this is not what CEOs of
these companies do I wish they did so I
would love to have Zuckerberg and Jack
and the rest of them in here to talk
about these things because I think it
can allay a lot of the fears that being
said there's gonna be a certain amount
of people that their fears won't be late
or a new set or crop up I'll keep
talking about it I hope you guys will
keep trying to get better at what you do
and maybe next time I'm in San Francisco
I'll jump up there and come to the
offices and tender great we'd love that
that's going on and and I thank you for
coming in and the conversations
obviously gonna continue and and maybe
we can facilitate something with Lauren
or whatever else there is and thanks for
thanks for doing this thanks for having
me Dave all right and thank you guys for
watching and of course we will continue
the discussion about this today and for
the next weeks and months coming and if
you're not a supporter on patreon and
Jack has said anything that makes sense
to you and you appreciate it what we do
it's patreon.com slash rubin report
you